in hundertste geburtstag muss gebührend
gefeiert werden auch wenn durch die
korona krise eine große party nicht
erlaubt ist mein alter kamerad heinz
bauer feiert heute seinen hundertsten
geburtstag
da die pandemie die vorgesehene
einladung seines freundeskreises
unmöglich macht bleibt er in seiner
wohnung allein und auch über die
ostertage allein
so habe ich mir gedacht ich besuche ihn
überrasche ihn und feiere auf entfernung
mit ihm seinen ehrentag
eigentlich sollten 53 gäste kommen aber
wegen der korona krise dürfen sie nicht
[Musik]
die irdische punktlandung
[Applaus]
1 ich habe hier ein kleines paket
mitgebracht nein damit über die
ostertage nicht hungern muss und damit
nicht so oft aus dem haus vom einkaufen
laufen ein ständchen auf dem dudelsack
ein paket voller leckereien ostern ist
für heinz bauer gerettet und bald kann
die große party bestimmt auch nach
gefeiert werden
bisher rausgehen kann
[Musik]